good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight if you had told us just
four days ago that the byte
administration was funding secret bio
labs in ukraine of all places we would
not have believed you yeah i don't think
we're going to put that on tv no thanks
then if you told us that not only did
the administration fund these secret bio
labs in ukraine
but that they then failed to secure the
deadly contents of those labs before the
russian invasion an invasion they knew
was coming an invasion they helped
encourage
if you had told us that four days ago
we'd have dismissed you as a nut it was
just too preposterous we wouldn't want
anything to do with a story like that
there was no way it could be true it's
too far out
in any case we already knew for a fact
that that story was false how do we know
that because we read usa today america's
newspaper
within hours of the russian invasion usa
today published a rebuttal to all those
crazies who are yammering on about
secret ukrainian biolabs
here's the headline fact check
false claim of u.s bio labs in ukraine
tied to russian disinformation campaign
so if you look carefully at the story
and we did because we were interested
you notice that this fact check was
sourced to ukrainian government unnamed
officials and then biden state
department officials these were not
exactly objective sources on this
subject but still the story seemed
definitive it was totally emphatic quote
russia has teamed up with china to
further amplify the false claim of u.s
labs in ukraine
okay
usa today says it's russian
disinformation maybe it is on to the
next story
but the fact checks didn't stop that was
weird we kept seeing the same fact check
again and again it was almost like
despite endless official clarifications
some people refused to believe the biden
administration they preferred russian
propaganda instead we assume they must
be q on members we assume that because
foreign policy magazine told us that
according to foreign policy q anon
whatever that is was frantically
disseminating quote false claims of u.s
bio warfare labs in ukraine
those labs obviously didn't exist it was
all just another lie from the russians
who lie for a living
then the european union weighed up
weighed in throwing its credibility
behind the same claim these are
conspiracy theories the eu told us their
lies spread by putin an eu spokesman
then reminded us that quote the
credibility of information provided by
the kremlin is in general very doubtful
and low that was good to know quote
russian disinformation has a track
record of promoting manipulative
narratives about biological weapons and
alleged secret labs
yeah we're not going to do a segment
about secret labs in ukraine last thing
we want to do on this show is traffic
and russian disinformation spread by q
and so we took a pass on that story
and that's where things stood until
yesterday when we happened to tune in to
a hearing of the senate foreign
relations committee tori newland was
testifying so we were interested new
ones one of the people who brought us
the iraq war never apologized for that
and kept getting promoted because that's
how dc works torrey newland is now joe
biden's undersecretary of state in
charge of ukraine and she knows a lot
about ukraine in 2014 torrey newland
engineered a coup in ukraine in the name
of democracy of course so she is a
highly informed source about ukraine
so she was having this colloquy with
senator marco rubio of florida during
her testimony and at one point rubio
took attack that we were not expecting
at all he asked nuland if ukraine had
biological weapons
we never imagined ukraine would have
biological weapons why would ukraine
have bio weapons
so it seemed like a pretty strange
question
but it wasn't half as shocking as the
answer he got watch what tori newlands
said
does ukraine have chemical or biological
weapons
ukraine has a
biological research facilities
which in fact we are now quite concerned
russian troops russian forces
may be seeking to
uh gain control of so we are working
with the ukrainians on how they can
prevent any of those
research materials from falling into the
hands of
russian forces should they approach
does ukraine have biological weapons uh
ukraine has biological research
facilities
what
you mean
secret bio labs like the secret bio labs
ukraine definitely doesn't have
ukraine has those yes it does
and not only does ukraine have secret
bio labs tori newlands said whatever
they're doing in those labs is so
dangerous and so scary that she is quote
quite concerned that the so-called
research material inside those bio labs
might fall into the hands of russian
forces
trying to use profanity on the air to
describe our reaction
our jaws drop let's leave it there
under oath in an open committee hearing
tori newland just confirmed that the
russian disinformation they've been
telling us for days as a lie and a
conspiracy theory and crazy and immoral
to believe
is in fact totally and completely true
whoa
you don't hear things like that every
day in washington talk about a show
stopper and a dozen questions instantly
jump to mind
what exactly are they doing in these
secret ukrainian bio labs ukraine is the
poorest country in europe it's hardly a
hotbed of biomedical research
we're assuming these weren't
pharmaceutical labs probably not
developing new leukemia drugs
from your answer tory newland we would
assume because you all but said it that
there is a military application to this
research they were working on bio
weapons again your answers suggest that
why would we fund something like that in
ukraine
and why didn't you secure the contents
of these bio labs before the russians
arrived as you knew they would and then
why did you go out of your way to lie to
the american public about all of this if
the quote research materials in these
labs were to escape somehow and you seem
very concerned about that what would be
the effect on ukraine and then on the
rest of the world
how can we prepare for the consequences
of that this thing that you're worried
about shouldn't we be preparing because
as it turns out we've just spent the
last two years living with a pathogen
that began in another foreign biolab
funded by the united states government
secretly so this question is on our mind
it seems fair
now that's some of what we would have
asked if we were u.s senators which
we're not yes there's a time limit time
limit be damned because this is kind of
important
but rubio did not ask those questions
instead he changed the subject and told
us once again that vladimir putin is bad
watch
if there's a biological or chemical
weapon incident or uh or attack inside
of ukraine is there any doubt in your
mind that 100 it would be the russians
that would be behind it there is no
doubt in my mind senator and it is
classic russian
uh technique to blame on the other guy
what they're planning to do themselves
okay
just get a pen
it's a classic russian technique to
blame on the other guy what they are
planning to do themselves that's what
tori and newlin said we almost laughed
out loud so what you're saying tori and
newland
if for example you were funding secret
bio labs in ukraine but wanted to hide
that fact from the people who were
paying for it in whose name you were
doing it then you might lie about it by
claiming the russians were lying about
it in other words you might mount a
disinformation campaign by claiming the
other guy was mounting a disinformation
campaign is that what you're saying tory
newland
it's pretty funny
what's not funny is that this is all
entirely real
we invited marco rubio on this show
tonight to tell us what he knows about
these bio labs he declined to come that
invitation remains open in the meantime
let's review what little we do know
about this
we're going to start with a spokesman
for the russian defense ministry on
sunday now we would never do this we've
never played anything like this on the
show before because of course we're
americans and we want to know what's
going on we ask our own officials the
people we elect and whose salaries we
pay because it's our country we don't go
to foreign sources because we trust our
own sources first
but when it turns out the people who
represent us and run our government are
lying to us and never apologize for it
and doing horrific things in our names
then you have to open your mind a little
bit at least assess what other people
are saying so here was the russian claim
watch during the course of the special
military operation facts were uncovered
of the ki regime mopping up traces of
military biological program under
development in ukraine financed by the
u.s defense ministry
okay so that apparently we hadn't seen
that until this afternoon we started
poking around that may have been
the root of the conspiracy theories that
the fact checks told us were russian
disinformation let's quote it military
biological programs are under
development in ukraine financed by the
u.s defense ministry that's the russian
claim
separately a russian foreign ministry
spokesman said the ukrainians were
working on deadly pathogens including
plague and anthrax is that true now
obviously we would not take russia's
word for that ever
but we don't have to take russia's word
for that the u.s defense department has
a website that contains this media clip
about the opening of a biological
research facility in ukraine in 2010
quote
u.s senator dick lugar applauded the
opening of the
interim central reference laboratory in
odessa ukraine this week announcing that
it will be instrumental in researching
dangerous pathogens used by
bioterrorists the level 3 biosafety lab
will be used to study anthrax
tulimeria and q fever as well as other
dangerous pathogens
oh
okay
then the national pulse dug up a 2011
report from the u.s national academy of
sciences that also explained that the
odessa-based laboratory quote is
responsible for the identification of
especially dangerous biological
pathogens
so what we're doing this is not the
first time you've heard this story we
are funding the creation of deadly
pathogens so we can study them and
prevent people from getting infected
with them maybe
there are lots of examples of this the
us embassy in ukraine has a handy web
page explaining that american and
ukrainian scientists have worked on a
whole bunch of different experiments
like this some of the projects include
work on african swine fever virus
hemorrhagic fever virus and various
avian rep respiratory viruses
the interesting thing the telling thing
is that the us embassy's website also
contains links to fact sheets about
america's support for biological
research in ukraine
but all those links are now dead
that's weird it's our government we pay
for it again they're there in our name
in the name of american citizens but we
can no longer read their web page how
does that work exactly they have no
right to lie to us
the web page is archived thankfully and
the fact sheets show defense department
funding to laboratories in ukraine
so that looks like proof it's not
russian disinformation it's totally real
sorry usa today america's newspaper it's
real
you can look it up on the internet if
you
want in the face of that evidence the
pentagon is still lying about it and in
fact they're repeating the same
unbelievably stupid and now thoroughly
discredited lies the fact checkers have
told four weeks now here's the spokesman
for the pentagon john kirby today
the russian accusations uh
are absurd they're laughable
and
you know in the words of my irish
catholic grandfather
a bunch of malarkey there's nothing to
it it's classic russian propaganda and
uh and uh i wouldn't uh if i were you i
wouldn't give it uh
i wouldn't give it a drop of ink worth
worth paying attention to yeah but but
can you explain to us what has there
been any relationship between them we
are not
not
developing biological or chemical
weapons inside ukraine it's not
happening
if i were you i wouldn't devote a drop
of ink to it first of all you didn't get
to make that decision mr bureaucrat we
have a free press in this country
you don't get to decide
but you'll notice at the end of that
kirby refuses to answer the question
has there been a relationship between
the u.s pentagon and a bio-weapons
facility in ukraine and if so what is
that relationship that's russian
disinformation what's the answer
we're not developing wmd in ukraine
right now okay got it
but why are we funding this and what
exactly are we funding we reached out to
the state department separately and they
provided us with this very carefully
worded statement quote the us department
of defense does not own or operate
biological laboratories in ukraine
not that anyone said they did
continuing the quote under secretary
nuland was referring to ukrainian
diagnostic and biodefense laboratories
during her testimony which are not
biological weapons facilities what's the
difference exactly continuing the quote
these institutions counter biological
threats throughout the country
end quote so that means nothing
you could describe our nuclear stockpile
correctly as defensive our nuclear
weapons are not designed to preemptively
kill anybody they're designed to prevent
other people from killing us but they're
still nuclear weapons
so why don't you stop lying and telling
us what's going on here and why don't
you more specifically tell us why you
didn't secure
these materials
so yes we're funding secret bio labs in
ukraine but they're diagnostic and
biodefense laboratories that counter
biological threats
okay if these are purely defensive labs
why was tori and nuland so concerned
that russians would get a hold of the
materials from these facilities
other world powers have come to the
obvious conclusion again we hate to do
this but under these circumstances we
asked our own spokespeople they lied
we're going to the foreign ministry of
china a country we despise
here's what they said today they're
calling on weapons inspectors to take a
look at these facilities in ukraine
right away
over the past two decades the united
states has been blocking the
establishment of a verification regime
to the biological weapons convention and
refuse to accept the inspection of
biological facilities within and outside
its borders
the move has further aggravated the
concern of the international community
we once again urge the u.s to provide
full clarification of its
bio-militarization activities within and
outside its borders and accept
multilateral verification
oh they're putting russian chinese
propaganda on the screen yeah we did
we also put u.s government propaganda
on the screen and the difference is we
expect to be lied to by foreign
governments we're not globalists we
believe in one country it's this country
the united states we do not expect to be
lied to by our government and we won't
accept it but let's get
to the substance of what the chinese
government just said we never agree with
the chinese government on anything but
in this case they make a fair point
we now know that dangerous biological
agents whether you call them weapons or
not is completely irrelevant because
they can be used as weapons is a gun a
weapon not when you're quail hunting
when you're in a gunfight it is
it's a ridiculous semantic debate
dangerous biological agents remain
thanks to the bite administration
unsecured in a chaotic war zone
at some point we need to know how that
happened who made those decisions we
have a right to know and let's hope
someone in congress apparently not marco
rubio but someone else will get to the
bottom of it but in the meantime we pray
that somewhere in the united states
government there is an adult who cares
enough to get this situation under
control immediately hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else